president trump fighting for his
political legacy as new questions
surface over his fitness for office in
the final 11 days of his presidency
mr trump lost his primary megaphone
overnight when twitter permanently shut
down his personal account
breaking off his connection to nearly 90
million followers
they also suspended one used by his
campaign this is calls from both
democrats and some republicans intensify
for the president to resign or face a
potential
second impeachment for inciting
wednesday's deadly storming of the u.s
capitol paula reed begins our coverage
at the white house this morning paula
good morning
good morning jeff multiple sources tell
cbs news president trump
will not resign and as momentum builds
on the hill to impeach him for a second
time
he's been banned from twitter the
platform he used to attack his political
enemies
often defend himself and he is even
credited with helping him win the white
house
in 2016. at real donald trump has
tweeted for the last time
late friday the president's preferred
social media platform
banned him in a statement the company
said the decision
was due to the risk of further
incitement of violence
the move came as extremist groups are
calling for
another round of attacks on washington
and
state capitals on january 17th
the president responded using an
official at potus account
tweeting a lengthy statement where he
declared we will not be silenced
twitter swiftly deleted those tweets and
said further use of that account
will be limited with just 11 days left
of his presidency
house speaker nancy pelosi called for
president trump to immediately
resign otherwise she said she is
prepared to move forward
with 25th amendment legislation and
a motion for impeachment the draft
article of impeachment
incitement of insurrection alleges that
president trump's conduct on wednesday
gravely endangered the security of the
united states
he would be the first president to be
impeached twice
but some republicans believe there just
isn't enough time
i've got enough decisions to make about
things that can happen rather than to
spend
time on things that can't happen the
final decision about whether to hold an
impeachment vote next week
will come from speaker pelosi who spoke
to 60 minutes as leslie stahl
on friday is anybody running the
executive branch
of the government who is running the
executive sadly the person who's running
executive branch
is a deranged unhinged dangerous
president of the united states and only
a number of days
until we can be protected from him
but he has done something so serious
that there should be prosecution against
him
cbs news has learned that republicans
are increasingly under pressure
to support this impeachment effort and
defend their institution against this
unprecedented attack cbs news has
obtained
this memo from the office of senate
majority leader mitch mcconnell
it lays out a timeline for a possible
senate impeachment trial
but because the senate does not resume
substantive business until january 19th
the first day this trial could even
potentially begin will be the day before
the inauguration
of president-elect joe biden dana all
right paula we will all be watching
thank you